hi i'm steve carell and these are five
of my favorite villains
my first favorite villain is the shark
from jaws
that shark was just this this character
an eating machine
no no thought no empathy and completely
terrifying the shark from jaws inspires
the character of grue in the the eyes
because sharks are known for having
extremely inexpressive unexpressive
non-expressive eyes
and there are moments where gru sort of
goes into that that dead shark eye look
and it's terrifying i remember going to
a theater and i grew up in massachusetts
and jaws was shot
on an island off of massachusetts in
martha's vineyard
and i remember that summer we went to
martha's vineyard on family vacation and
i never went in the ocean again
i think it had that effect on a lot of
people
the design and look you know in modern
terms not so great you know you see a
lot of the flaws in the actual the
technical aspects of the shark itself
but that suspension of disbelief as a
child and really everybody just bought
into it and apparently the shark was
always breaking down and so they had to
cut a lot of the the visuals of the
shark out and just have those the air
containers whatever those were that were
you know that indicated that the shark
was nearby those yellow tanks and that
built the tension so i think it was
almost what you didn't see of the shark
which uh made it even more insidious i
think my favorite line was
so i thought that was a pretty good one
second favorite villain is the mayor
from
the movie jaws
because he
did not close down the beaches
and he jeopardized a lot of people's
health and well-being and uh so i think
the mayor from amity
was uh
was a villain and kind of a jerk because
he really just cared about making money
on the fourth of july weekend come on
man it's a shark in the water don't do
that to people i think my favorite scene
with mayor from jaws was when he said
i'm not shutting down this beach no
matter what it words to that effect
i know that's i don't know that's
exactly the dialogue but it was
basically that what did i like about the
aesthetic of the mare
from jaws well
um i don't know if it was
i don't know if it was an aesthetic per
se
but he gave off a tone of arrogance
and entitlement
and he too
had sort of those dead eyes much like
the shark because for him
it was all about revenue and what is
worse than that besides just being an
eating machine
i don't think he's pure evil but i think
there's conflict
in him as a character because he wants
to do what's right obviously he cares
about the town he cared enough to
run for mayor but i think over time and
this is back story that's never talked
about never discussed probably invented
in my own imagination
but he started as a young politician
in amityville
and he's reached the pinnacle and now
he's uh he's a little
uh overconfident
and now he just sees dollar signs so
i think in effect the whole movie jaws
is about
the transition um and and sort of the
the coming to a dark side for that one
character
or or it's not that at all
the impact of jaws well i know the
impact that it had on me is literally i
didn't want to go swimming in the ocean
ever again and i still think about it
that opening sequence
when uh the woman is swimming swimming
at night no way there's like
there's no way that would ever happen
and i actually i shot a movie where i
had to be out on a surfboard
and i was a little scared we were in
northern california
and but i kind of put it out of my mind
spent the day out on a surfboard
shooting these scenes
and then they pulled us into the zodiac
this this pontoon boat at the end of
shooting and the guy the guy driving it
said hey do you see any sharks out there
and i was laughing like i thought he was
joking he said no no really like around
the bay that is a shark breeding ground
so this area is known to have had a lot
of
shark deck and they didn't show me the
sign at the
at the foot of the beach there's a sign
that has a big shark on it and it says
no swimming so
uh i'm glad i didn't know that until the
end of the day i would have been
even more terrified than i was so i
don't i i think i think it had a
societal impact in the sense that it
scared people from i know it did in
massachusetts and um it's certainly in
martha's vineyard that i think they're
this swimming uh
at least for a few summers it took a
backseat
quint from jaws because quint was he's
sort of an anti-hero but i would see him
as a villain because he he brings
sheriff brody and hooper out on the boat
and then he scuttles it so they're stuck
out there because he's got this vendetta
against this shark so it's it's him and
the shark like dude
don't you have to bring these other two
out there to die with you
you know so that i think there's a
little villainy in in him as well and
again i think a lot of it like the mayor
comes from hubris it's about him it's
about
him you know being so
self-centered that he has to
have his moment with the shark but he
brings potentially brings two other
humans down with him i think people
misunderstand his accent because like
that guy did not grow up in amityville
like i don't know what it is is it maine
is it
is it is he welsh i don't know i don't
know where that character is from and i
think there's
i think that therein lies a
misconception with quint quint getting
eaten i i think just overall
that scene in the film is my favorite
because it happens very slowly as shark
attacks go
and it's incredibly graphic the the
the shark
is leaning on the back of the boat just
doing that with his mouth and quint just
slides down in and he's gotta he's he's
got a you know like a hatchet with him
or a like a big machete and he's trying
to you know chop up the shark that's not
gonna work it's a good scene
my fourth favorite villain
is hannibal lecter he's just he's a very
complicated intriguing villain charming
smart
probably a genius
but
certainly has some
some components missing as a human being
the opening scene where you first where
he's first revealed it's unlike anything
i've ever seen in a movie jody foster's
character clarice is walking and i think
everyone remembers us through
the you know down the hallway of the the
high security prison
and the way the camera pans around and
just reveals him standing there in the
middle of the cell
um
anticipating her arrival it's
there's something
obviously incredibly creepy about it
but
at the same time there's a formality
almost a politeness to it that he is
presenting himself to greet her
i enjoy the fava bean line but it's what
he does after the fava bean that
it just seemed so spontaneous
and so odd
that it
i have never
in my life thought you're talking about
food or anything that you love to eat
and then going
that doesn't seem you know you lick your
lips maybe you go yum yum yum fava beans
with little chianti yum yum yum but not
it's a very memorable moment for sure
fifth favorite villain is the shark from
jaws 2.
the fact that after all this hubbub the
first time around the shark just i don't
know
a relative
you know somehow they communicated
like this this town is good eating you
gotta get over there
um and our friend
bill got blown up
so
you know there's still plenty of people
to eat over there so you should head on
over and sort of just the
the arrogance of that like yeah you know
let's double down on this one town and
try to eat some more people it just
doesn't seem doesn't seem right there's
no
there's no respect there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]